really noticeable you know you'll be
hearing us like we need together the
reason that Elise is not moving here is
because of something that I'm not proud
of
hi my 90 day fans fam its melissa here
what an episode of 90 day the other way
i was intrigued we're gonna get into
everybody's business in just a few but
first we have to talk about ten and may
Lisa because I have been waiting for
this one there's no way that I expect
her to trust me or believe me again but
Tim finally revealed the shocking thing
he did to discourage Melissa from moving
to the US the main reason that I decided
[Applause]
on that's it really I don't know why I
was expecting for it to be something so
much worse don't get me wrong I don't
condone cheating I think cheating is
horrible I think it's bad but let's be
real here people I definitely thought
Tim did something way worse I just knew
Tim did something crazy I definitely
understand now though why Melissa did
not want to uproot her life for someone
who quite frankly didn't buy you her
heart Tim did go on to reveal the extent
of his cheating it wasn't just a date
and it wasn't just a kiss
all the way last year the distance
between me and my lease at that time was
very difficult I felt lonely and the
girl that I had altima treated with was
a co-worker you know I just started off
his casual conversation and it got to a
point to where we did have a full-out
intimate sexual encounter message here
people it's okay to feel lonely you
don't always have to try to fix it you
know sometimes it could just be a great
moment for introspection if you go out
seeking other people to fill that gap
for you you might end up like Tim who
made a rash decision and allowed his
loneliness to mess up a whole good thing
I actually spoke with Tim a few weeks
ago and he hinted at the fact that
Melissa was worried about him seeking
affection outside of their relationship
so it was her idea to get Pepe the cat
so he can have some extra love from a
support animal ya know it was her idea
to get the cat just because you know
kind of a testament to her how she is
always thinking about other people you
know before we really knew what we were
gonna do live together this and that she
didn't want me to be alone and she
wanted me to kind of have some support
so that's what got her to come around on
him and then once we got him she she
kind of you know maybe forgets at times
that if that's what it was for
that's her boy I cannot get Tim crawling
on the grass with Pepe the cat on a
leash out of my head hilarious next up
we have another music artist on our
hands we got introduced to Bingham who
recently started his music career and
goes by the name baby cool don't say
nosey nosey don't say baby cooed I'm
here for it I'm here for it
and finally Devon's mom who has never
been out of the country had a meltdown
as soon as they made it to Korea
what are we talking about are we going
[Music]
that's just how they drive here okay why
the prep see ya
you'll get mom thank God my mom doesn't
know F what Devon's mom started to
stress me out okay
and it doesn't even stop there just wait
and so they see where they'll be staying
she goes again to me where it where
where we uh where's the house
this is the new house
[Music]
also next week Ginny confronts summit
about those divorce papers again when am
I gonna see these divorce papers Epsom
it lied to me about Marley for his
divorce I would have to leave the
relationship and ariela makes it to
Binion's apartment well how's this this
bathroom looks like something from one
of the Saw movies
yikes well I read my 90 day fans fam
make sure you stick with ET because we
are covering it all mwah see you next
time
[Music]